hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to no escape it's a horror
game isn't any good I don't know let's
play alright a little bit too energetic
here but I think you all understand my
recipe of ignorance when I go into these
games I don't know what's going on and
that's more to the betterness of this
gameplay of things that I do I do these
things
laughs mouths bondic lip pickup
batteries okey dokey
haven't played just a typical oh hello
space to reload flashlight huh so gonna
be like that you're gonna have it based
on winners Washington not based on what
was washing the mail wide about 35 years
of age suffering from religious mania he
is stupid lying in a nude condition on
the floor he imagines that he sees Jesus
Christ God Almighty etc will be kept
locking starve until he can stop
preaching when I ask him questions head
orderly Austin Flint well then that's
interesting left mouse button to drag
drawers so I'm assuming ah it's
physically interactable that's
delightful and also got one of six pages
I don't know if this is gonna be like
slender but the environment seems to be
a little bit more physically
interactable than I've seen in the past
anything for me no I like it
amnesia like doors this might actually
be something good anything in here any
monsters want to rear their ugly heads
not that you're ugly I think you're all
very beautiful monsters but you know
just don't oh hello well this was a fun
room in here let's high-five how's it
going
we're good to see ya hug the neighbors
out the family has a kid what are you
doing I can't look away
thanks huh
have a good one see you at the barbecue
alright that was weird what the hell was
about that I remember this from that
movie that Angelina Jolie was in she got
this electrocution shock therapy and it
was totally to stop her quote/unquote
hysteria I forget the name of the movie
but you all probably know what I'm
talking about at least some of you did
anybody so that was a cool head in the
corner I'm glad he was there really
uh-huh
Sarah mannequin on that desk
hmm
Oh God boo hi sorry didn't quite notice
what you were at first but uh how's it
going good good
hi again you weren't here for what are
you doing oh good
where did you all come from could I go
home now
hi why can I please yes please thank you
okay what was up oh my god it changed
it's so cool in credo okay don't do it
again
hello hi okay only came back in here
because okay all right bright bright
bright sunshiny day so I just came back
in here because I think there might have
been something else in here but I was a
liar there's nothing else here okay this
game has got some tricks I like it
he's got some hutzpah some originality
to it no not the mannequins are totally
original but at least it's doing some
clever mechanics here I like it a lot I
hate mannequins though some people don't
know because I haven't played many games
of mannequins involved in them that
mannequins are my least favorite thing
in horror games I mean oh god damn it I
just used another battery uh I need to
watch that because it does get very dark
but I accidentally hit it again no
another note here we go
well then who's spooky scary skeletons
come on you have to do better than that
well look an exit well I don't have a
key so that's moot um I haven't even
found any other oh hi how you doing
you're looking good
nightmarish been good so what the hell
am I supposed to find here okay I don't
know how to crouch down so I don't know
if there's actually anything in there
but I guess I'm just gonna continue on
my way ah the atmospheres of these games
trying to get to me cuz as soon as I
start a new game like this I'm always
like hey happy new game I can't wait to
play it it's gonna be so much fun and
then though the SU patient is an
abomination a taunting of our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ it doesn't know
anything or he doesn't know anything
about the good book but now that he's
here I aim to teach him he will live by
my rules and God's rules are suffer may
God have mercy on his wretched soul
Austin Flint so this is a very religious
okay stain I gotta go if you don't mind
I'd rather go thank you
don't know if that was always there but
if it was the good I'm glad a new
battery in okay uh hated good okay glad
really show your emotions let it all out
why is there a heartbeat in here I got
really quiet there's a heartbeat in here
why why is someone banging on a door
over there
oh what's that oh wait this is where I
came in okay so I just circled around I
need to find okay so you kicking it up a
notch I see well don't even bother I'm
far too brave and handsome and also
strong but that doesn't really factor
into these horror games I mean I can
actually pick up stuff and move doors
I'm much stronger than the usual oh hi
again
can you stop doing that and I know
you're not actually doing anything but
could you stop just standing there
menacingly I don't much care for it did
you move why are your hands claws I
don't like that I don't like anything
about you normally I like things I'm a
nice guy but you are trying my patience
okay look like like god dammit where'd
that go that fall through okay and I
said unto God who deserves life and he
said unto me no one but you my child I
will deliver them all from this well
hell so someone's really happy about
things death oh I thought you meant
hated okay it was an anagram was an
Agora s-- who that is bright okay I need
to find three of our pages and also get
a key somewhere don't know where I'm
gonna find witch but someone stomach
growling over there someone better not
be hungry for the taste of human flesh
thank you for rearranging those books I
did want all those books on the other
shelves you you gonna do anything oh
that's the same thing it did before come
on be a little original here okay oh
these can open I thought these couldn't
open I'll maybe give only the top one
can open
well dang it I probably missed out on
some stuff if I wasn't able to open
those I'm gonna have to go back
I thought those are it nevermind what do
we have here anything that I can read
hospital records for this weird-ass
place
oh hi there you I can do that too and
you need your jacket would be a good go
help yourself oh wow there's writing on
there and say yes I can't read all that
someone else translate for me ah God
wills Washington solitary confinement
yesterday wills told mortally that he
plan to cleanse this earth of its evil I
do not believe we are safe around him
the devil has dug his claws into him
will not let go okay god damn you're
you're awfully persistent guys can I get
out of here thank you thank you god damn
it those wowed then again for these
horror games I usually have my volume
way turned up in my headphones
okay still got batteries I'm good to go
this is literally the worst flashlight
I've ever had in my life okay I I can't
read your messages anymore they don't
make any sense well as Washington has
shown great improvement since he landed
in our care he's not due for solitary
confinement I was asked in the future
your friend from citing religious
beliefs in your medical Doctrine okay
thanks doc your opinion is greatly
appreciated in the scenario I'm sure
that nothing will go wrong in accordance
with your oh okay well hi that's good
y-yeah what the hell
excuse me oh okay don't go that's the
other way okay I have a I need to
double-check these top drawers in here
just to make sure that I didn't miss
another note because I'm I'm five of six
but I think that I've missed something
oh wait there was another one on the
other side let me just check that any
psychotic killers in here I've wanted to
clear themselves long before they run
into me surprising I haven't actually
run into a monster at all anybody want
to say hi I'm friendly
kind of I'll probably punch you in the
dick though just for warning it's not my
fault you jump out at me punch right in
the dong okay so nothing in there I
think there well I got the key I don't
know if I absolutely need five of six
I'm just doing it to try to be thorough
but oh oh oh god damn it it was just a
payback never mind okay there's a
wheelchair
oh god I'm out of batteries who-who do
come on
academically dang it all right I don't
know I'm right by the door with that his
lock so I'm gonna go in new through did
I won oh where am I now this isn't what
you promised me I thought I was gonna be
done after that well geez now I gotta go
through it again what do I gotta do wait
a minute No
oh my god is this the same oh my god
wait am I in the same place as I was
before oh no you did not
maybe it's just cuz all the doors kind
of look the same wait a minute no no no
no stop it
it's not creepy get away from me I'm not
I'm not gonna fall for it this time wait
a min thats not fair this affair you
just drop me off back where I was before
what are you doing what do you mean what
am I gonna do it again this is baloney
malarkey what is happening did I win
I don't know if I've won maybe he's
sending me back because I didn't get all
the what is going on okay so this level
is different while also at the same time
being the same I'm wondering if it was
randomly generated in any way okay there
was one in one of those okay so this
time I'm in actually okay there's the
exit over there I'm actually gonna try
to get all the pages then I'm gonna go
to the exit after I get all the pages
but now that I've actually checked all
these medical places
hi hey neighbor hey Cassini again champ
buckaroo nee how you doing family good
ah problems at home I understand that
they all ball and chain if you know what
I mean well I'll see you around the
neighborhood inhale
Oh No thank you that was new that did
not happen before this game slightly
random that what you're doing to me cuz
I should warn you I know a lot of
martial arts styles me Rochelle are not
normal martial arts but miracle arts you
don't want to miss be I'm a man on the
edge oh wait there there there oh I
would have almost missed that Jesus okay
I only need two more whoopty woo woo I
don't wanna Nana nanana Nana Nana na
neun another one well hi excuse me a
little privacy here please thank you
okay this more than one oh god there's
three oh thank you oh why do you keep
draining my battery like that please do
not soar another battery under the other
is good god this battery sucks ass it's
better six like ten anuses okay cool
thanks is a key and there's a note and
the student becomes the teacher the
devout becomes sinful in the world will
burn does that look like it's written on
human skin because that is a little bit
of a flavor of human skin to it I'm just
gonna go in all the room ah damn you
that didn't scare me at all ah this way
this way okay so I've got six pages I'm
just assuming you're actually gonna not
be a douching let me win what what what
okay
I'm guessing I've won and well and truly
that is the end of the game I'm just
gonna assume okay whispering okay I I
guess there's no ending in place yet the
game may not be complete I'm pretty sure
I did everything it required of me so
either way there you go
that is no escape maybe that's the I oh
oh oh I can make someone sense okay I
understand now so either way that was no
escape maybe I didn't get to the ending
maybe you guys can find something else
here that is more ending like than what
I found either way links in the
description below thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more scary games that I've done there's
so many of them leave a like if you
enjoyed this video and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye